foreign
the demand for business analyst is
dramatically increasing as a result of
digital Revolution business has been for
as long as civilization but what has
changed is our ability to access vast
amount of data on how our business
function these professionals are one of
the highest paid today after watching
this video you will understand what are
the steps involved in becoming business
analyst we will learn in detail about it
in this video so before moving forward
please make sure you subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates so
what's in it for you
we will understand who is a business
analyst next skills required to become
one
roadmap to become business analyst roles
and responsibility and salary and job
offered for a business analyst let me
tell you how simply learn can help you
start your career in business Analytics
all you need to do is to open
simplylearn.com and search business
analyst
the system master program in business
analyst with simple learn offers you in
collaboration with IBM which can help to
build your career by learning tools like
Microsoft Excel jira power bi MySQL
numpy and programming languages like
python or R and libraries like sci-fi
matplotlib Etc this master program will
definitely help you build your career in
business analytics enroll today and help
yourself to become successful business
analyst who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who works
with companies to study their systems
services and products in order to
enhance present operation and come to
profitable judgments
a business analyst
evaluates the business model and how to
integrate it with technology to assist
organization in documented business
processes
a business analyst is responsible for
processing and analyzing the products
and services to make profitable decision
to improve the financial activities of
the organization business analysts
handle all the requirements demanded by
the clients and convey them to the
product development team now it's time
to learn skills required to become
business analyst
analytical skills and critical thinking
great Achievers are great thinkers
the role of the business analyst comes
at the beginning of the software
development lifecycle a business analyst
must analyze the client requirements
effectively critical thinking helps the
analyst in examining different
situations and providing a solution
communication skill every role demands
communication skill but communication is
the key for every business analyst they
are supposed to have talked with
stakeholders a good business analyst
needs to have communication in different
phases be it with clients product
development team
or the implementation team for instance
if a product needs to be implemented
then it is the duty of a business
analyst to communicate with the clients
regarding requirement clearly otherwise
the entire project May collapse as a
business analyst facilitating meeting is
very important first point to boost your
confidence if you have good
communication skill database and SQL
SQL is an important skill that every
business analyst needs to understand a
database is a software to store the data
business analysts should have hands-on
experience on SQL from which they can
fetch data from these databases so it's
better to know MySQL Oracle DB no SQL or
mongodb
programming skills it's good to know
programming languages like python or r
business analysts have to deal with lots
of data that are beyond the limits using
spreadsheets so if you know Python
programming language it helps in
analyzing the data as well as we can
easily integrate it with SQL databases
to automate tasks
R also works in the same way R helps to
create interactive graphs and help in
analyzing the data
reports and dashboards business
dashboards are increasingly seen to help
business analysts to produce data in an
insightful way
dashboards are Consolidated with charts
and graphs on a single screen the
purpose of dashboard is to help business
analysts by allowing them to gather and
analyze the data let's say we have 10
sets of people working on a project we
have to maintain a dashboard in such a
way that it is understandable and
accessible to everyone so that everyone
can understand the growth of the project
these were some of the important skills
business analysts need to have
how to become a business analyst if you
are a fresher this is a very important
part
ly it's essential to decide and
concentrate on the fundamentals of the
business analytics understanding the
fundamentals and choosing the right path
are crucial in every field start
learning the fundamentals of business
analytics first and start mastering it
pursue the related course it's a
reminder to you to have a look at the
business analyst master program link
which is given in the description box
below
you can take up a business management
course and get certified to become
industry ready
internship an internship is a fantastic
way to learn more about a field or job
you might like to pursue internship in
business analytics will help you deal
with real-time experience working in
Industry this will automatically improve
your resume start taking up real-time
projects on Business Development and
Analytics lastly apply for a job
build a portfolio including your
practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary this used by
business analyst we have covered some of
the important tools frequently used by
business analyst based on its use
project management tool jira the
collaboration tools jira and Confluence
are very practical to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jeera by
using platforms like jira all business
stakeholders May engage with various
teams and view the status of their
project
Trello is a project management platform
businesses use for teamwork and task
organization dividing the work into
columns on a boat enables you to manage
your projects and effort dividing
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
help simplify and standardize your work
so for this purpose Trello is very
important tool
data visualization
the main use of data visualization tools
is the ability to quickly solve business
related problems Tableau is the prime
software for data visualization it
creates efficient visualization which
makes the stakeholders understand the
data more effectively
power bi is a software created by
Microsoft that meets your analytical and
business needs a visit allows access to
data even when using third-party
programs and services for instance you
can integrate it with SQL Server you can
enable python with power bi tool that
offers customizable visualization by
including data normalization and
purification the functionality of a
desktop program can be greatly increased
using power bi as we have already
learned reports and documentation is the
key skill for a business analyst to
create report and documentation we use
Google Docs Google Docs provide you with
templates for business research business
analyst may share and collaborate on
documents effectively using Google Docs
with the use of Google docs business
analyst can communicate with
stakeholders about any kind of file or
document
Microsoft PowerPoint as we previously
discussed good presentation skill is
always counted for a business analyst a
business analyst must have ability to
present project teachings to their
stakeholders so it's necessary to learn
Microsoft PowerPoint these were the
important tools for a business analyst
to manage their work now comes roles and
responsibility played by a business
analyst in Industry a business analyst
has a variety of roles and
responsibility therefore it is crucial
to understand thoroughly the roles and
responsibility held by business analysts
before learning how to become one
a business analyst pinpoints the goals
and issues of a company's business and
develops profitable Solutions
the assembled stakeholders and business
requirements they help in analyzing and
evaluating business processes an
organization has and identify the area
of improvement
business analysts collaborate with the
development team to create a plan for
addressing a specific issue they
aggressively offer feedback on the
design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that a company needs
business analysts evaluate companies
functional and non-functional
requirement different roles performed by
a business analyst are data analyst
business architect system architect and
product manager these are the roles
which are interdependent on a business
analyst in an organization so the top
companies hiring a business analyst
they are Accenture IBM Deloitte TCS
VMware McKenzie and Company we can also
include meta in this list this is the
job description provided by Accenture
for a business analyst role key
responsibility will include working with
clients and Technical Resources to
identify their business problem and
developing the analytical solution good
knowledge and understanding of digital
application
planning and managing business diagnosis
and planning activities understanding
and analyze functional impacts on front
to back application design and document
new process and system changes
performing interpreting requirement
analysis to identify value creation
opportunities for clients on average
Accenture offers 76
000 dollars per year for a business
analyst Rule now we will see job
description in IBM so what will be your
responsibility being a business analyst
in IBM be part of international teams in
the design build test run faces of
customer projects from various
Industries and interesting business
domains this role as its clients and
projects in implementation of wide range
of application and business processes
communication with business owners and
end user to Define business requirement
and with development team to ensure
delivery to the agreed standard and
quality support testing in the
resolution of Defense learn and apply
processes and methodologies related
latest it Trends from both the JD we can
understand that business analysts have
to deal with clients a lot
so on an average eighty four thousand
dollars per year is the salary offered
for a business analyst working in IBM
and the final part is salary of a
business analyst
the average salary of a business analyst
for refresher is seventy thousand
dollars per annum in USA and experienced
is one hundred thousand dollars per year
experience level you should be able to
evaluate and measure business Frameworks
and how they influence an organization
and their clients
coming to India the average salary of a
business analyst
for a fresher ranges from 8 lakh per
year for experienced it can go as high
as 15 lakhs per year and more also such
as the demand for business analyst all
over the world you are prepared to begin
your career in business analytics
because you have a better understanding
of what business analyst does their
roles and responsibility and steps
involved to become one I hope the video
was helpful thank you for watching and
keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here